de lo que voy a hablar en este vídeo es
de la regla del producto y bueno en este
vídeo no vamos a demostrarlo pero pues
vamos a conocerla y ver un ejemplo de
cómo se aplica lo que la regla del
producto dice básicamente es que si
tienes dos funciones digamos que una de
ellas se llama ese jefe de x que está
multiplicando a otra función g de x y lo
que nosotros queremos es calcular la
derivada de fx porque de x con respecto
de x entonces tenemos que resulta ser
igual a la derivada la derivada de la
primera función multiplicada por la
segunda función ojo esta segunda función
no la estamos llevando
más la primera función solita sin
derivar por la derivada de la segunda
función cree entonces tenemos dos
términos y en cada uno de esos términos
tomamos la derivada de una sola de las
funciones ok en la primera en el primer
término tomamos la derivada la primera
función y la multiplicamos por la otra
función tal cual y en el segundo término
dejamos la primera función intacta y
multiplicamos por la derivada de la
segunda función o sea cada función su
derivada aparece en alguno de los dos
términos y en el otro no y en cada
término hay un término que es una
derivada de una de las funciones y otro
que es la función tal cual bueno veamos
un ejemplo digamos por ejemplo que
queremos calcular la derivada con
respecto de x de x cuadrada por 100 9 x
como aplicamos la regla de la cadena
pues podemos ver aquí que esta expresión
tiene la forma de dos funciones
multiplicándose sea por ejemplo podemos
poner f de x igual a x cuadrada que es
este x
7 x igual a 100 9 x si están de acuerdo
que si ponemos f x cuadrada y gtx igual
a seno de x entonces esta expresión es
simplemente fx porque x
y bueno ahora también lo que vamos a
necesitar son las derivadas de estas
expresiones entonces sacamos la primera
derivada de fx y cuál es la derivada de
x cuadradas
pues la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x
y ahora con la derivada de seno bechis
pues como pueden consultar en un
catálogo que tiene muchas derivadas la
derivada estreno de x es coste de 9 x
también en algún otro lugar de la página
de khan academy está demostrado que
efectivamente coseno x es la derivada de
sinovitis y bueno ahora sí estamos
listos para calcular esta derivada
usando la regla del producto
entonces la derivada con respecto de x
de x cuadrada por seno de x es igual a
lo primero es la derivada de fx ok la
derivada de fx habíamos quedado que fx
será x cuadrada esto es la derivada de
fx es 2x
2x por gx ahora gm x s 9 x 60 x
más buscamos fx o sea x
por la derivada de que de equis o sea la
derivada de este 9 x que está por aquí
sea coseno de x y listo
esa es la derivada